[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
bafou nous allons parler notamment
d'écologie de climat mais aussi des
césars mais aussi de la 5g mais aussi de
ces sondages peut-être un peu inquiétant
sur l'état de la france et pour en
parler en plateau florence mercadé
choqué bon jour en jour tetris avocate
au barreau de versailles
stéphane minson bonjourbonjour patrice
est professeur à l'université de
versailles saint quentin est avec nous
en duplex comme on disait autrefois and
gardens bezina bonjour bonjour patrice
maître de conférences à l'université de
rouen
vincent couronne bonjour fondateur du
mouvement des surligneurs qui corrige
les erreurs dans les discours politiques
et vous êtes l'auteur nos podcasts sur
les contre vérités dites sur l'europe
qui s'appelle objection votre europe et
jean charles lajoie ni bonjour bonjour
vous êtes éditeur
merci d'être avec nous et notre invité
c'est jean philippe dugoin clément
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
vice-président de du conseil régional
chargée de l'écologie et du
développement durable vous êtes aussi le
le maire udi de mennecy et justement il
vient de se passer à paris mercredi et
jeudi
la coop régionale c'est à dire la
conférence sur le le climat ça va être
le premier chapitre de cette émission le
climat
[Musique]
alors d'abord commencé par une question
d'actualité
il ya eu la convention citoyenne sur le
climat le président de la république
avait adopté la plupart des mesures
voulues par cette convention citoyenne
et puis hier on a appris que la taxe
carbone sur les transports aériens ne
serait pas adopté ces 2 le ministre de
l'économie
bruno le maire qui a fait cette annonce
alors c'est assez intéressant parce que
évidemment écologiquement c'est
important cette taxe sur les transports
aériens mais les compagnies aériennes
ont vécu les que ça coûterait à peu près
150 mille emplois je vais commencer avec
vous j'en fais du coin clément est ce
qu'on n'est pas justement dans cette
problématique qui est assez compliqué de
l'environnement de la lutte pour
l'environnement des mesures favorables
en effet pour le pour nous mais
peut-être qu'ils coûtent sur le plan
économique
oui bien sûr c'est toute la difficulté
de l'adaptation de la transition
environnementale aujourd'hui c'est
comment est ce qu'on l'a rend
supportable soutenable pour des citoyens
pour les français pour les habitants de
la planète en général entre ce qui est
bon et ce qui est possible
moi je crois énormément que sur ces
sujets là on doit investir massivement
au niveau des pouvoirs publics pour
trouver les seuil d'équilibré
parce qu'effectivement beaucoup de gens
entre le souhait la volonté est là le
réalisable font face à un accueil
extrêmement forts envoyés pendant cette
coupe que vous évoquiez qui n'était pas
que climatique on était vraiment sur
l'ensemble des questions
environnementales de la transition vers
de talent au sens large
par exemple on parle notamment des
questions d'alimentation et on
s'aperçoit quand on parle de
l'alimentation qu'on a aussi un décalage
aujourd'hui entre la tante croissante
des français des franciliens pour avoir
plus d'alimentation de proximité plus de
bio plus de maraîchage sur notre région
avec une véritable diversification qui
n'existe plus qu'un disparu qui s'est
amoindrie tout au long du xxème siècle
mais dans le même temps le réflexe de
donneurs d'ordres carte bleue si vous
voulez d'une certaine manière de la part
des consommateurs
donc là un des grands sujets c'est
comment faire en sorte que chaque
français chaque citoyen devienne une
certaine manière non pas victimes de
quelque chose qui est imposée mais
deviennent citoyens acteurs de par ses
choix de vie ces modes de vie et ses
modes de consommation on voit à quel
point quand on parle de la taxe carbone
on est à la limite de l'exercice
et puis ça pose aussi une autre question
quand on parle de la taxe carbone sur
les transports à rien on parle de ce qui
existe aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut aussi c'est se projeter
vers l'avion du futur l'avion du futur
on sait bien qu'il ne sera jamais
électrique on n'a pas la capacité
technique à le faire on a aujourd'hui
hydrogène on en parle énormément
ça fait un an sur la région ile de
france candidat investi voter un plan
hydrogène l'allemagne la france le
portugal on en parle assez peu mais de
manière colossale par rapport à ce que
nous faisons par rapport à sa population
décline des plans hydrogène de manière à
pousser la recherche de manière à
décliner des écosystèmes vertueux qui
permettent d'aller vers une énergie qui
est décarbonée qui est propre qui est
infinie moi je crois et même en la
question d'investir dans la recherche
pour préparer cette transition est ce
qu'on est beau c'est que on ne le fait
pas assez par rapport justement un ovono
notamment les quelques partenaires
européens et d'autres pays commencent à
le faire l'annoncé dans le cadre du plan
de relance d'un plan de 5 milliards sur
les dangers des enfants des importants
d'allemagne en 2009 le portugal me
semble-t-il 6 à 7 pour une population
beaucoup plus faible mais on commence à
le faire je crois que c'est sur des
sujets sur lesquels on est en retard et
c'est des sujets sur lesquels d'ailleurs
on pourrait gagner à avoir beaucoup plus
de liens de coopération européenne en
mutualisant les moyens qu'on met de part
et d'autre du rhin sur ce sujet là alors
on va revenir cette coupe régionale le
but d le thème c'était de dresser un
bilan des enjeux et d'apporter des
réponses concrètes qui est un peu vague
mais alors quels sont les enjeux et
quelles réponses vous apporter je vais
rester général brésil
vous l avez raison fondée sur des sujets
qui sont infinies non on a eu un peu
plus de deux jours en valais dans ledit
sujet précis après pardon on a eu un peu
plus de deux jours de débats sur à peu
près toutes les thématiques du chant
environnementale qu'on parle de
l'énergie qu'on parle de la biodiversité
qu'on parle de la renaturation qu'on
parle du lien économie écologie qu'on
parle de la réindustrialisation du
rapatriement d'activités qu'on parle de
la santé environnementale et des
questions sanitaires qu'on parle de
l'alimentation qu'on parle de l'égalité
des droits
on avait prévu une coop qui devait
initialement se dérouler sur une semaine
avec énormément de colloques de visite
de déplacement ont l'art concentrer sur
deux jours avec des intervenants aussi
bien représentants des lycées que
représente la convention citoyenne que
gros chef d'entreprise de
multinationales élus acteurs associatifs
chercheurs scientifiques pour sur
l'ensemble de ses champs à voir d'une
certaine manière un benchmark de ce qui
ce fait des retours d'expérience des
effets de ddd faire acte de propositions
parfois de manière contradictoire ou
pouvant être provocant piquante mais
c'est aussi le but du jeu et surtout on
a souhaité au sortir de cette coop
s'engager nos régions ile-de-france sur
quelques 200 propositions 200 actes de
ce colloque qui sont pour nous une
feuille de route des mois et des années
qui viennent alors certaines sont des
actions que nous avions déjà pu entamer
et que nous souhaitons massifier par
exemple quand on parle de la création de
500 km2 est en ile-de-france pour
recréer des zones des espaces de
biodiversité sur des espaces de grandes
cultures
on a commencé à le faire mais on va il
massifier d'autres peuvent être des
sujets absolument majeures comme le
lancement de la révision du sdrif sur le
schéma directeur de la région
ile-de-france qui est un schéma
d'aménagement pour inclure toutes les
dimensions environnementales dans son
spectre parce que quand on parle de
l'aménagement d'une région qui augmente
sa population de 60 et d'habitants
chaque année une région en croissance
économique constante ce qui n'est pas le
cas de toutes les régions françaises
mais l'île de france est très
particulière de ce point de vue là ça
veut dire aussi qu'il faut qu'on adapte
nos
outil réglementaire de calage et de
cadrage urbanistique pour mettre le
pense le champ environnementale dedans
donc c'est pratiquement 200 propositions
qui ont été actés et qui seront la
feuille de route francilienne des mois
et des années qui viennent dans d'écossé
spectre de domaine qu'on peut retrouver
sur deux sites de de la région
évidemment évidemment alors il y avait
il y avait un mot et le tout sans parler
qui était important dans cette danse est
cops et le mou d'indépendance ce soit
sur le plan de l'énergie
que ce soit sur le plan de
l'alimentation ce que ce soit sur le
plan de la santé notamment sur le plan
de l'énergie
il y en a toujours ce débat en france
sur le nucléaire qui nous happe sur la
dépendance énergétique et en même temps
qui est contestée par beaucoup
d'écologistes
alors je vais vous demander d'abord à
vous votre point de vue est ce qu'il
faut continuer l'énergie nucléaire ou
pas ou comme comme les deux ponts
certains écologistes c'est ce qu'il faut
passer à d'autres énergies c'est
l'indépendance dès l'indépendance
nationale independence francilienne la
froide l'ile-de-france est la région la
plus dépendante du pays avec 90 % de
notre énergie qui a importé m'ennuie %
de nerfs sur la question du nucléaire
il ya clairement deux sujets il ya
l'état actuel et qu'est ce qu'on veut à
10 20 30 40 ans quand on parle d'énergie
il ya deux sujets aujourd'hui c'est la
production des gaz à effet de serre et
le réchauffement climatique l'énergie
nucléaire est aujourd'hui le principal
facteur massif de production d'énergie
qui n'augmente pas le l'effet de
réchauffement climatique quels principal
souci auquel on est confronté non me
dire vouloir couper
aujourd'hui l'énergie nucléaire est
quelque chose qui n'est pas tenable
ce qui est important pour moi je suis
pas pro nucléaire c'est la question du
trend vers lequel on veut aller vers
quoi on veut aller à 10 20 30 ans est-ce
qu'on se donne les moyens de réduire et
remplacer progressivement d'aller vers
autre chose
les nerfs
seul sans le développement de
l'hydrogène ne le permettrons pas la
massification d'hydrogène ça va être
plusieurs années plusieurs décennies
travail pour le faire couper le
nucléaire aujourd'hui ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne c'est augmenter notre bilan
carbone c'est augmenter le réchauffement
climatique
donc moi je crois pas à la déclinaison
du nucléaire comme étant l'alpha et
l'oméga et ce sur quoi tu de pont poussé
dans les 10 20 ou 30 ans qui viennent
mais je crois à une transition réfléchi
travaillé et progressive quelques balles
intervenir sur le sur ces dames du
nucléaire c'est totalement en phase avec
ce que vient de dire jean philippe
dugoin clément le ciel est même encore
plus loin je pense que effectivement on
verra peut-être dans 40 50 ans si ici on
a des recherches des choses qui ont pu
faire on arrive à quelque chose de plus
propre mais pour l'instant l'énergie
nucléaire c'est la plus propre la moins
chère la plus écologique
alors après il faut pas tomber dans
certains travers il faudrait que là on
parle beaucoup de parfois des
engagements de l'état et les blancs que
ce soit toujours l'état qui dirige et
qui s'occupe du nucléaire quelque chose
de trop trop important la sûreté
nucléaire etc
pour qu'un jour ça puisse échapper un
contrôle très précis mais effectivement
le nucléaire et que et quand on voit
comment enfin je veux dire comment se
sont conduits les allemands je veux dire
qui cela on parle d'europe et ce sur
l'eau et l'europe dans angela merkel qui
décide du jour au lendemain de couper
tout truc nucléaire qu'il est maintenant
démerdez vous nous on va dire c'est un
scandale absolu et je veux dire il faut
bien fondé du nucléaire
c'est trop facile quoi un pays de l'ue à
bâle nous on va être super clean les
différents n'abandonne nucléaire on
achètera l'énergie ailleurs où on va
remettre du des centrales au charbon
donc bien évidemment le nucléaire c'est
pour l'instant la solution peut-être
qu'on aura une plus propre bientôt ça
fait d'accord avec jean philippe dugoin
clément et cherchons d'autres cherchons
d'autres choses cherchons d'autres
pistes et ça va être extrêmement
extrêmement longs extrêmement lent donc
pour l'instant il n'ya pas elle n'est
même pas de débat
il devrait pas y avoir deux pas de
nucléaire ou poursuit on l'améliorent en
améliorant la sécurité on a mis dans le
rendement de ses centrales et on arrête
de critiquer toujours puis et puis bon
voilà après
une chicane alors moi je trouve qu on
touche ici à tout le paradoxe du champ
lexical de l'indépendance dès qu'on
parle de la souveraineté de la question
de récupérer d'indépendance sur le
médicament le climat etc
on touche à cette idée du patrimoine de
la fin de la mondialisation de quelque
chose qui permette de pouvoir toujours
s'en sortir en cas de crise je crois que
ça évidemment du bon dans des situations
d'urgence on s'est rendu compte à quel
point avec la crise qu'on avait vu qu'il
était important de pouvoir être
indépendant financièrement mais pas que
néanmoins sur la question de l'énergie
l'indépendance
elles nous ont pas forcément assurée
exclusivement par le nucléaire on en a
parlé
la recherche d'énergies renouvelables
propres
elle continue et continuera et je crois
que ça n'est pas une question de
souveraineté qu'on aborde ici c'est
simplement une recherche mondiale de
survie de l'espèce que ça commence sur
le long terme et qui est menée aussi
bien par la presse que par d'autres
états mais je pense qu'on a ici un
paradoxe c'est à dire que contient à la
fois cette énergie parce qu'elles
semblent aux assurés de la souveraineté
et à la fois on n'est pas certains de
ses effets on est gouverné par ce
principe de précaution qui nous impose
aux conduite prudente finalement dans
nos recherches
donc y'a ce paradoxe là mais je crois
que l'urgence a en effet eu une sortie
du nucléaire
souvent incontrôlés presque sentimentale
et passionnel il faut évidemment qu'on
cherchait des solutions alternatives
sans objet et les bonnes choses qu'on a
déjà trouvé à mon sens il ya des thèmes
c'était l'indépendance
sur le plan de la santé rappelle le
disais on avait vu avec la crise du
chrono virus qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de médicaments importants qui
sont fabriqués en chine qu'on a eu du
mal
rapatrié au moment où on avait besoin
mais en même temps est-ce qu'on n'a pas
été un peu déformés par sept par cette
crise ou de la cuve vide parce que après
tout faire fabriquer des médicaments qui
coûte moins cher ailleurs en temps
normal c'est plutôt pas mal sur déformé
par cette crise
et je crois que cette crise a montré la
dépendance absolue que nous avons n'est
pas uniquement à terre le soutien que
nous avons dans l'ère moderne avec les
autres alors c'est ce qui a fait aussi
la force de cette mondialisation
c'est-à-dire qu'on a dit que vous pouvez
être aujourd'hui citoyen du monde et
c'est ce qui a fait cette force là mais
dans les situations crise une part
d'indépendance elle est réapparue
nécessaire notamment pour des raisons
une charge c'est-à-dire que si on n'a
pas le temps si on n'a pas la
possibilité d'avoir des contacts avec
l'extérieur
c'est important qu'ils se débrouiller
tout seul je crois qu'il faut à
fantasmer autour de cela non plus une
parade et commensal est nécessaire au
chantier mais avec c'est un peu et
finalement à l'élan et sexy il ya il ya
une prise de conscience qui a été
intéressant tout recentralisation la
main d'oeuvre
évidemment c'est quelque chose
d'absolument il n'y a pas de
mondialisation heureuse
moi je pars en tournée dans une période
en tout cas où la mondialisation est
assez contesté on le voit dans les
sondages
sauf qu'on s'en sortira pas je crois
qu'il ya une mondialisation
fondamentalement heureuse au delà de
tout ce qu'on peut dire et des slogans
politiques qui eux ne font que ne font
que passer et séduire ponctuellement
certains certaines clientèles
électorales ce qui moi ce à quoi je
pense nous sommes confrontés c'est une
inter dépendances
et cette interdépendance allait elle est
à la fois positive est souhaitable dans
de multiples dans de multiples domaines
on parle d'eux
du réchauffement climatique la recherche
scientifique etc tout cela ne peut pas
évidemment se concevoir à une échelle
locale régionale nationale
tout cela ne peut se concevoir qu'à une
échelle planétaire si on veut raisonner
de manière efficace et c'est évidemment
là tout là toute la difficulté pour
qu'on le voit bien pour cette question
l'énergie nucléaire il sufit à quelques
à quelques centaines milliers de
kilomètres on rallume des centrales à
charbon pour que tous les équilibres qui
qui qui a pu être plus ou moins atteint
soit soit totalement bouleversé donc
cette interdépendance
elle est me semble-t-il pour pour une
large part un atout et elle doit être
cultivé tout en considérant que sur des
questions d'ordre stratégique est
exceptionnelle on peut parler en effet
de stocks stratégiques qui permettent en
dans les moments de crise de faire face
mais je ne crois pas une seconde à 7 à
cette affaire d'indépendance climatique
énergétique etc
les choses se régleront tous ensemble ne
se règleront pas justement jean philippe
dugoin clément alors il ya cette coop
régional avec ses 200 mesures dont vous
parliez mais la lutte pour le feu pour
le contre le réchauffement climatique
par exemple la lutte pour un meilleur
environnement
stéphane vient de le dire elle est
mondiale et quand on voit par exemple
le président train dire bat contre les
incendies en qui on avait déjà calé fort
du rebond vous savez ça ça passera et le
réchauffement climatique ça n'existe pas
est ce que ça ne rend pas un peu
difficile de lutter justement pour un
meilleur environnement ou pour pour un
apaisement climatique et qu'elle est
longue au fond d'une région par rapport
à cet enjeu mondial c'est de prendre sa
part vous savez c'est la théorie du
colibri où c'est la parabole du colibri
c'est que si chacun ne prend pas d'une
certaine manière sa part on ne s'en
sortira pas
drôle de la région d'île de france il
est particulier on est la première
région française la deuxième région
européenne en terme de population
on représente deux millions trois cent
mille habitants sur une population
supérieure à la belgique enfin c est
quasiment un état en tant que région
n'avons pas les compétences régaliennes
d'un état mais on représente un état
européen d'une certaine manière et donc
notre sujet c'est comment est-ce que
nous agissons concrètement dans les
secteurs qui relèvent de nous alors
après nenê finalement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec la disparition du
permafrost qui est un sujet normalement
de production des gaz à effet de serre
absolument colossal en sibérie ce qui se
passe avec ball sonar au brésil selon la
conception climato-sceptiques peut avoir
un donald trump qui brasse énormément de
morts peut-être que ça rafraîchit le
climat j'en sais rien sur ces sujets la
ronde parfois pessimiste sur ce à quoi
on peut être confrontés mais je crois
que notre rôle c'est que chacun prenne
sa part c'est que chacun agisse louis
eux dans son domaine de compétence et
essaie d'inciter d'accompagner les
autres à le faire savez nous région
alors effectivement à travailler sur
notre territoire régional
mais en même temps on travaille sur un
certain nombre de coopération on a une
douzaine de coopération avec des pays de
langue d'histoire ou de patrimoine
culturel francophone qui souvent ont des
liens avec l'île de france 2 par des
d'aider des populations issues de ces
pays qui vivent en ile-de-france on
pourrait parler de certains pays
africains du vietnam de de l'arménie et
que nous accompagnons
en termes de partenariat en termes de
coopération en termes d'études en termes
de gestion de déchets en termes souvent
de deux questions environnementales en
termes de lutte contre la pollution de
l'air donc c'est aussi essayé dans le
cadre des moyens ou des compétences qui
sont les nôtres et bien de travailler
d'avoir des liens veiller sur cette cup
on avait par exemple des représentants
de dakar on avait le gouverneur adjoint
d'abidjan en côte d'ivoire qui sont des
régions avec lesquels nous travaillons
nous essayons d'avoir des liens parce
qu'il ya les mêmes problématiques
voyez de la semaine prochaine ont adopté
une stratégie régionale pour l'économie
circulaire appelant après le plan
régional de gestion et de réduction des
déchets l'année dernière une stratégie
d'économie circulaire par exemple c'est
comment réduit l'impact carbone sur le
bâti en devenant moins dépendant en
essayant d'aller vers une réutilisation
des matériaux de déconstruction dans le
bâtiment on sait que le bâtiment est un
des facteurs majeurs de production de
gaz à effet de serre avec les transports
dans notre région est bien la région
d'abidjan travaille également sur la
mise en place d'actions pour développer
une économie circulaire avec des
problématiques qui peuvent être
différents mais vraiment je crois que le
rôle qui est l'autre si non seulement de
faire chez nous mais d'essayer de faire
partout on peut accompagner
après quand on parle de trump de bolton
à roue et bien c'est un travail d'état à
état
et effectivement on ne fera pas la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique la
lutte pour la transition
environnementale tout seul et c'est
aussi des fois les limites de quelques
prises de positions extrêmement
dogmatique ou doctrinaire qu'on peut
voir dans notre pays et qui allait me
tend une logique quasiment le
culpabilisation sur des choses qui
peuvent être relativement anecdotique ou
qui peuvent rendre l'écologie
profondément impopulaires plutôt que de
s'intéresser aux problèmes macro je vais
pas revenir sur ces maires qu'ils font
dans le tout biologique
allez on va parler de tout à l'heure
peut-être il ya un débat là actuellement
en france puisque c'est celui sur la 5g
je voudrais qu'on collabore maintenant
c'est le deuxième chapitre de l'émission
c'est donc la 5g alors justement de
développement de la 5g il ya eu cette
phrase du président de la république je
ne crois pas que le modèle amish
permettent de régler les défis de
l'écologie contemporaine c'est vrai
qu'il ya des dessins débat sur
l'assemblée il ya des sondages
d'ailleurs assez contradictoires
certains disent que 65% des français
seraient opposés la 5g bien un autre
sondage paru dans le parisien qui montre
que même une majorité d'économistes sont
pour la salle j'ai donc on va pas se
fier aux sondages qui ont peu
d'importance
vincent couronne est ce que vous
comprenez vous vous qui avez une
mauvaise liaison internet
non je plaisante
est ce que vous comprenez ce débat sur
l'a50 bonnes questions patrice je suis
toujours pas pas le seul à 5 g mais
pourtant là ma connexion aujourd'hui en
france fonctionne bien donc
comme quoi en fait le problème de la
salle g je pense c'est que beaucoup de
gens ne voient pas les apports concrets
la 5g
il y a ceux qui sont déjà la 4g et qui
trouve ça très suffisant et puis ceux
qui n'ont pas accès à internet tout
simplement et qu'ils se disent que ça ne
changera rien pour eux et puis il ya
aussi je pense le fait que pendant la
crise sanitaire vient pour un jeu
trouble et par le docteur didier raoul
ce qui a quand même pas mal atteint la
crédibilité des scientifiques et on ne
compte plus les théories complotistes
sur la copie décès comment dire ces gens
là ont fait dans ces circonstances
comment peuvent ils faire confiance à à
la 5g et le débat sur la scène j'essaie
donc on peut dire je vends mon avis je
pense que c'est la préfiguration de ce
que notre société
tous médias sociaux sera demain il y
avait une polarisation des politiques
des positions partisanes des camps qui
ne se parlent plus si on regarde cela
c'est que j'ai les promoteurs disent que
cette technologie va nous sauver va
révolutionner des détracteurs disent
qu'elle va quasiment j'exagère à peine
tu es en tout cas nous rendre malade et
donc voilà donc on est dans cette
situation là et du coup comme personne
ne s'écoutent et bien le gouvernement ne
prend pas en compte les arguments des
opposants et on les compare à des amish
alors que certains peut-être des choses
intéressantes à dire si on regarde
notamment dans les pays qui ont déjà
mises en place à 5 g on remarque à une
grande différence avec ce que la 4g à
porter mais c'est vrai que potec ça
prend du temps et c'est donc pense que
le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est que
on est dans une polarisation qui fait
que plus personne ne s'écoutent et les
arguments des uns et des autres ne sont
plus en tant d'âmes
jean philippe dugoin clément sur le seul
à 5v voûte est en effet responsable de
de l'ecologie du développement durable
au conseil régional
quel est votre point de vue je ferai pas
la liaison entre le kama sutra et les
amish sur ce sujet ou sur aucun autre
ensuite sur la 5g très calmes on a eu
exactement les mêmes débats les mêmes
peurs par rapport au déploiement d'un
téléphone mobile de la 3g de la 4g
on mesure les craintes les peurs
qu'engendre tout changement tout
changement
je rappelle que les mêmes mouvements qui
aujourd'hui sont contre la 5g sont ceux
qui avaient en ile-de-france interdit le
déploiement du wifi dans les lycées
alors créant une fracture sociale
extrêmement forte pour des lycéens
défavorisés la 5g effectivement je pense
qu'il ya un rôle d' explication entre
allemands forte parce que beaucoup de
français ne voient pas l'apport
l'intérêt la nécessité ni un besoin
d'explication pour rassurer par rapport
aux craintes la réalité de la scène j'ai
c'est que ça ne joue pas tant sur les
niveaux de consommation individuelle sur
ses téléphones
c'est que c'est le déploiement des
services en ligne quand on parle outil
intelligent quand on parle de voitures
intelligentes quand on parle de
toutes les évolutions potentielles on a
besoin de débits beaucoup plus important
quand on nous explique et c'est une
réalité que pour réduire le bilan
carbone pour réduire le niveau de
pollution
il faut arriver à développer à massifier
le télétravail il faut arriver à
massifier le rapprochement travail
domicile il faut arriver à s'appuyer sur
des services nouveaux
on ne pourra pas le faire sur l'a5 j'ai
donc je pense qu'il ya un moment où on
ne peut pas quand on est élu s'amuser
uniquement à surfer sur les peurs à
rajouter sur les angoisses
il ya un moment un devoir de
responsabilité un devoir d'explication
il ya un devoir de savoir vers quoi on
veut aller voilà le tout sans aucune
provocation en tenant compte des peurs
légitimes qui sont celles des français
mais aussi très souvent les gens ont
peur du changement
quels qu'ils soient ils ont valeur de
l'évolution et le rôle des responsables
publics c'est quoi c'est d'expliquer
c'est de rassurer ses de justifier ses
devenir pourquoi est ce qu'on fait il ya
une histoire que raconte un nazi dire
comme ça qui chaque fois qu'on installe
un poteau satellite il ya tout de suite
des plaintes de gens qui disent qu'ils
ont mal à la tête
il est il raconté qu'est ce qu'ils vont
dire quand ça sera branché mais c'est un
peu ça résume un peu c'est pas très
rapidement anne charlene
beau contre la cinquième ou partager
évidemment je rejoins tout ce qui a été
dit notamment par vincent quan
évidemment on débatte plus à part les
émissions de paf
mais on a on n'a pas de possibilité
d'entendre des arguments rôdés avions
honte qui soit vraiment crédit mais sur
lesquelles on puisque en goûtant
l'inconvénient de bassac j'ai aussi
c'est qu'on a l'impression que la
technologie avancée plus vite que la
recherche puisque on ne connaît pas
encore mais effet précisément de quelque
chose que nous n'avons pas encore mis en
place mais du coup ça donne un peu notre
sentiment être devant mais voir dehors
c'est à dire qu'on a quelque chose qui
évolue tellement vite qu'on n'a plus le
temps de maîtriser les effets cela je
crois que c'est ça qui nous inquiète
parce qu'on est vraiment dans notre
avenir dans notre écologie dans notre
bien-être au niveau de la santé aussi
c'est qu'on s'inquiète de quelque chose
qu'on ne connaît pas et qu'on ne
maîtrise pas dansé et fait donc
peut-être que si les décideurs arriver à
nous dire que des études ont été faits
plusieurs décisions de justice ont été
pendus justement sur la scène j en
précisant que c'était encore quelque
chose qui est dans l'expectative donc le
jour où on aura du concret peut-être que
cela permettra de nous rassurer
j'ai l'impression qu'on commence à
anticiper un bémol aux quelque chose qui
n'est pas encore certain donc c'est
peut-être ça qui suscite beaucoup
angoissent s'était pas de mention vous
qu'il y avait un téléphone 1 g je pense
que tu as les fans de la deuxième chaîne
de la deuxième génération
donc je je je ne n'étais pas conservé
non non je suis concernée en tant que
citoyen mais enfin je vois là je je je
je me suis documenté sur les
possibilités et les avancées
remarquables que ce que ce que cette
cinquième génération peut apporter
je pensais par exemple la télémédecine
etc je sais absolument indéniable mais
d'autre part je pense qu'on supporte de
moins en moins de ne pas savoir est que
nous n'acceptons pas de ne pas savoir
et donc la sagesse dont dont il faudrait
qu'on essaie de sa de s'approcher tous
c'est que tant que je ne sais pas je
suspends mon jugement et vincent
couronne avait avait raison de faire
allusion au professeur didier rahout qui
a décrédibilisé pour des décennies
une partie de la parole scientifique
c'est le ou ce sondage qui demandait aux
français quelle était de se prononcer
sur les effets de le doxie chloroquine
oui on est toujours là la première fois
vous voyez un sondage sur sa voie et
médicaments united et ça ça me fait
penser à cela - la simple le cette
cinquième génération je ne je ne suis
pas scientifique dans ce domaine là donc
je ne sais pas je suspends mon jugement
pour l'instant un avis justement
peut-être un petit duel alors vous avez
une minute chacun pour recompter chargé
alors je pense que jean-charles vous
êtes pour florence mercadé choqué vous
êtes plutôt mesurée on va compenser par
les arguments pour assez rapidement à
une minute chacun jean charles lajoie ni
le premier argument c'est qu'on peut pas
aller toujours les seuls à toujours tout
critiquer et tout remettre en cause
dire que le monde entier va s'équiper en
5 g et il ya quelques quelques personnes
qui voudraient que la france arrête un
peu comme autant de rester rixe le petit
village gaulois d'un enfermement bâle où
on est plus intelligent que les autres
on sait on est tous scientifique 67
millions de français qui savent qu'ils
maîtrisent parfaitement les normes
techniques pour savoir c'est vous ou pas
vont donc il faut arrêter avec ça on va
pas la corée du nord pour moi n'est pas
un modèle
donc on part sur la singulier bien
évidemment après la seule vraie question
n'est pas adapté pour ou contre la 5g
mais plutôt qu'est ce qu'on va faire de
la 5g et que tous les gens qui hurlent
contre la 5g ferez mieux déjà dit mais
de beaucoup moins se connecter parce que
si la 5g les intéresse qui ne ce qu'ils
ne passent pas leur vie sur leur
ordinateur sur leur téléphone en
télétravail en faisant leurs courses sur
internet etc
c'est un changement de société donc il
faut puisque on pousse les gens
inexorablement à rester chez eux à
regarder la télévision 24 heures sur 24
à faire leurs persos
sur internet au moins autant autant que
tout cela fonctionne c'est probablement
pas une société rêvez pas et finement
dramatique a plein d'autres à 5 g et
allemands à 10 ans encore une fois à
raison d'être pour contre tous alors la
voie la parole par allal attaque d'une
de la 5 v6 poésie française mercadé
choqué alors une première réflexion
c'est que je suis très étonné quand même
de la déclaration de notre président
dès lors qu'il avait quand même 10 par
rapport au rapport aux élus par les
citoyens demandant un moratoire sur la
5g et nous a bien dit qu'il allait tout
appliqué de ce rapport ce qui ne fait
pas puisque en gros ils traitent les
citoyens damisch qui avait demandé un
moratoire ce que je trouve quand même un
peu surprenant
ensuite il faut regarder la 5g telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui je suis assez
effectivement convaincu que en termes de
recherche scientifique technologique
c'est quelque chose d'assez formidable
mais il ya deux choses il ya d'une part
effectivement tout ce qu'ils recherchent
tout ça me paraît important tout ce qui
peut être sur la santé sur l'évolution
des technologies tout ça j'ai pas de
débat là dessus
aujourd'hui il ya des notamment il ya eu
un rapport qui a été rendu dans le monde
s'est fait l'écho hier où actuellement
la singette en corée du sud en
angleterre en allemagne et en et en
irlande et le rapport indique que c'est
plutôt pour le moment un an l'état c'est
plutôt un échec parce qu'il ya des
endroits où la 5g passe pas ou il ya une
conversation téléphonique sa coupe
alors que la 4g passe très bien donc il
ya quand même des problèmes techniques
qui sont pas du tout résolu aujourd'hui
et tous les individus jeu honnêtement le
fait de télécharger un film
avec en une minute au lieu de le faire
en deux minutes
je pense que ça apporte pas grand chose
de là bas oui non mais vraiment dans
l'équation ça oui surtout quand ça dure
à une minute de moins quoi c'est pas la
4g moi je sais que ça marche très bien
en termes de télétravail ou te benoît
marché de la fibre qui marche super bien
donc je pense que déjà il faudrait
pouvoir mailler le territoire et lot
l'intégralité du territoire où il ya des
zones blanches encore aujourd'hui et où
manifestement pas grand monde sont aussi
intéresse donc avant de pouvoir déployer
quelque chose qui n'est pas au point du
tout aujourd'hui manifestement et puis
enfin il ya un problème de protection de
nos données puisque on sait qu'il ya un
briquet derrière quand bien même
apprendre à orange free et compagnie
mais ça n'empêche qu'il revoie être
derrière kim à mettre les tuyaux et il
faut faire très attention aux données
qui vont pouvoir être captées par les
chinois et ça c'est quelque chose qui
m'inquiète
merci alors chacun se fera son idée ne
montrent pas le jugement du président
relançant puisque je sais que vous
préférez attendre jean philippe dugoin
des mots sur ce sur ce sujet je reviens
sur ce que disait jean charles lajoie
nice est vrai que dans dans la coop
régionales il y avait il y avait une
table ronde sur le thème travailler
autrement et notamment sur le délai de
travail c'est vrai que le télétravail se
va devenir de plus en plus présent et
c'est vrai qu'il faut faciliter aux y
est de ce point de vue la 5g peut être
aussi une facilitation et est peut-être
un outil du changement de nos deux
façons de travailler
bien sûr c est contribuer après sur le
télétravail c'est il ya plusieurs sujets
il ya un l'adaptation des entreprises
autres les travail la domination des
mondiaux de travail jusqu'à quel point
il est soutenable est souhaitable parce
que au sens inverse c'est quelque chose
qui peut aussi notamment chez des
personnes les plus en situation de
fragilité crée des phénomènes
d'isolement des phénomènes quasiment
d'enfermement voyez quand on parle de 2
jugez d'égalité femmes hommes ça peut
aussi être un facteur parfois
d'augmentation d'un certain nombre de
disparités d'inégalités de renforcement
d'emprisonnement ou d'enfermement donc
le télétravail on est bien évidemment
cours y compris parce que c'est un des
moyens de lutter contre la pollution des
de france contre la sur saturation des
réseaux routiers que c'est un moyen peut
être artificiellement mais un moyen de
rapprocher domicile et travail que c'est
également un moyen de lutter contre
l'étalement urbain
l'un des sujets comporte aujourd'hui en
ile-de-france qu'on a réaffirmé dans le
cadre de cette coop c'est lausanne
lausanne cédé 0 artificialisation n'être
que nous inscrirons dans le cadre du
schéma régional de développement
franciliens comment est ce que dans une
région qui augmentent de 60 mille son
nombre d'habitants annuellement ou
l'épicentre parisien perd huit à dix
mille habitants
on arrive à protéger des terres
naturelles à rester une région agricole
avec 50 % de terres naturelles 25% des
espaces forestiers
ça veut aussi dire récupérer des espaces
de bureaux réaménagés des espaces de
bureaux non utilisés ou qu'on peut
récupérer en en réduisant la masse ça
veut dire travailler sur des friches
sarc répare tout va bien un mot florence
mais très désolé sur le télétravail
je pense qu'elle télétravail doit être
d'abord appuyé sur le volontariat
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ne
supportent pas le télétravail qui
n'aiment pas travailler chez eux ou
qu'ils ne sont pas capables vont pouvoir
se concentrer
plusieurs heures en restant chez eux et
10 ont besoin de la relation sociale
avec les autres là actuellement il ya
des
des discussions entre les partenaires
sociaux sur la possibilité de mettre en
place un accord peut être évolutif par
rapport à ce qui existe parce qu'il ya
quand même beaucoup il ya à la fois de
la législation et des accords de branche
et des accords d'entreprise mais moi je
ne suis pas favorable à télétravail à
100% comme on l'a vu on n'avait pas le
choix
pendant le confinement parce qu'il y en
a pas mal de personnes qui ont souffert
effectivement je pense que ça va générer
des inégalités hommes femmes puisque ce
sont plutôt les femmes qui vont être
c'est ça restez à la maison s'occuper
des enfants et travailler donc tous en
même temps donc ça c'est quand même un
peu compliqué qu'on fasse du télétravail
deux jours par semaine pourquoi pas mais
du coup ça ne permettra pas comme vous
le disiez monsieur de récupérer des
bureaux dans le sens où il faut que
c'est quand même des gens qui soient là
qui se passe les autres ils peuvent être
intéressés justement parce qu'il ya
moins de moins d'investissements sur les
mètres carrés de bureaux grâce au
télétravail
on va tourner elle a tourné dans les
bureaux et ça va être autre chose on va
voir c'est une tendance intéressante
quand même
en effet jusqu'à jusqu'où elle peut
aller philippe dugoin clément vous
parliez tout à l'heure des mr écolo qui
est des propres ou peut-être inquiétant
justement c'est la question qu'on me
pose est ce que ces écolos sont
inquiétants bah on parlait de la salle
faisait il ya le maire de grenoble pour
qui la sauve mais ça sert juste à
regarder des films pornos dans
l'ascenseur bon vous avez bien vu le
maire de lyon qui a qualifié le tour de
force de machiste et de polluants qui
est d'ailleurs tacler dans son édito par
franz olivier giesbert sur une autre
affaire c'est à dire qu'il a refusé
d'aller à une cérémonie catholique qui
date depuis depuis des années ce sens et
à laquelle tous les maires de lyon y
compris gérard collomb qui est
franc-maçon assister au nom de la
laïcité n'a pas voulu assister le
lendemain il posait la première pierre
d'une mosquée à gerland
ce qui fait dire à j'espère qu'au fond
les écolos sont frappés par l'islamo
gauchisme
on pourrait parler du maire de bordeaux
et des sapins de la mer de de rennes et
qui autorise à certains horaires des
burkinis dans les piscines municipales
stéphane manceau est ce que derrière ces
déclarations qui sont peut-être juste de
la maladresse mais est-ce que ça ça
dévoile peut-être le vrai visage d'une
certaine partie en tout cas des
écologistes absolument je suis d'accord
ce jeu je suis convaincu que ce ne sont
pas des maladresses puisque on a affaire
à des as des as des élus qui ne sont pas
si j'ose dire nés de la dernière pluie
gg la la galaxie verte et d'une telle
d'une telle hétérogénéité la galaxie
politique il ya presque autant de
courants qui lie à deux membres de
encore j'allais dire de europe ecologie
les verts c'est le sait la structure
politique la plus visible mais y en a
beaucoup d'autres
c'était une nébuleuse qui est
extrêmement extrêmement dense donc ce ce
discours là je vous avais oublié aussi
la savoureuse décision du maire de lyon
qui considère désormais que tous les
textes issus de la ville de lyon doivent
être rédigées en écriture dit inclusive
qui de mon point de vue est une écriture
ségrégationniste qui là où le notre
orthographe et notre grammaire unis
qu'il a des limites totalement divise
donc non tout cela de méthane absolument
pas je reconnais chez les verts une une
constante dogmatique et arrogante qui ne
m'étonne absolument pas vincent couronne
écouté patrice je suis assez d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire stéphane
mensonge simplement
donc je me rallie à la plupart parce
qu'il a dit simplement je rajouter une
chose pour essayer un petit peu de de
les sauver des postes et qu' ils sont
ils sont ils ont remporté des grandes
villes ils sont l'objet d'une attention
médiatique particulière et je pense que
on scrute on épluche lors des six durant
leurs déclarations à la loupe et qu' il
ya un effet déformant dans les médias de
toutes ces déclarations là et qu en
réalité si on regarde l'ensemble des
maires en france et même d'autres
granville on peut retrouver des
déclarations parfois tout aussi
irritante scandaleuse etc
voilà simplement je pense que les verts
occupent en pole devant de la scène en
son nom ça va sans doute se calmer je
suis pas sûr que alors ça ça les embête
pour de ce probablement pour 2022 je
suis pas certain que ça soit
rédhibitoire
on a tout simplement parce que je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils apprennent les colts
là la communication grand public
quand on est quand on est au pouvoir
pour vous c'est juste de communication
and charlène vézina duclair les deux
c'est à dire qu'à mon avis on avait
réussi un parti qui n'est pas
historiquement partie de gouvernance et
qui a donc ici à faire face aux néo
serment de la communication politique
c'est à dire de prendre des décisions
qui sont des purs artifices sont les
décisions du buzz et ont absolument
aucune pérennité ça c'est un peu le
premier danger et malheureusement pour
foncer tête baissée là dedans après
c'est sûr qu'à évidemment question qui
pèse sur eux donc peut-être aussi que
nous avons mis les sunlights sur
quelques décisions un peu un peu
d'affichage mais moi je crois au fou
rire
en tout cas 2022 c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'on m'ait dite c'est à dire
que l'écologie est un peu une étiquette
longs cous manière générique la gauche
la droite identitaire on n'arrive plus
vraiment à ce qu'on veut c'est un pote
dernier deux parties on avait le
sentiment
il avait une idéologie qui était forte
et cohérente mais en effet elle est loin
d'être unique parce que la fête dure
l'écologie c'est l'avenir donc une des
parties peuvent se l'approprier
une question s'est posée mais c'est vrai
que là on entend plutôt le le discours
punitif alors je sais que jean-charles
vous vous êtes partisan des verts et
voulait défendre
je suis admiratif des verts parce que
normalement on dit toujours que la bête
avancent masqués mais là les bêtes
avance démasqué c'est à dire que là ils
sont d'une rigoureuse honnêteté je le
vois pas la moindre maladresse dans ce
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils expriment
simplement ce qui pense profondément
c'est à dire que le maire de lyon pense
profondément que la patrouille de france
c'est de la merde pense que le tour de
france c'est de la merde
le maire de bordeaux pense
qu'effectivement il vaut peut-être mieux
que chacun ait un sapin en plastique
fabriqué en chine au lieu d'un sapin de
noël car a été fabriqué pour ils ne sont
absolument pas il n'y a pas de mensonge
c'est à dire que là au moins je leur jeu
leur donne un énorme satisfecit
on voit qu'ils sont on voit ce qu'il
pense je rejoins alors 100% franz
olivier giesbert ils sont il tombe bien
évidemment à pieds joints
mais ce n'est pas un piège c'est dans ce
qu'ils appellent de leurs voeux spade
islamo-gauchiste pense que ce qui les
définit le mieux je ne sais plus quel
homme politique avait dit ça mais d'ici
là les verts c'est vraiment des
pastèques verts à l'extérieur rouge à
l'intérieur on est vraiment là encore
une fois pas de maladresse ils pensent
vraiment ce qu'ils disent ces problèmes
en salle drame mais ça a au moins le
mérite d'éclairer les électeurs et je
pense que à bordeaux à lyon à grenoble
partout il ya des gens qui se disent
j'aurais dû aller voter comment est-ce
qu'on en est arrivé là et c'est eric
lansberg avait choqué effectivement je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit mais je pense que les
électeurs qui ont ceux qui ont voté pour
les verts ont voté d'abord avec une
volonté environnementale et quand on
voit l'histoire du
requis ni où l'écriture inclusive
strictement rien à voir avec le bulletin
vert et mais ça va avec et je pense
qu'il ya toute une partie des lecteurs
qui doit faire un peu tombé de l'armoire
et qui n'y reviendront peut-être pas
alors jean philippe dugoin clément il ya
ça pose une question politique
vous vous êtes membre de l'ue dit vous
êtes engagés sur les sur les questions
d'environnement
est ce que justement et on voit par
exemple le le p r essayer de travailler
cette question sur laquelle ce mouvement
est un peu en retard est ce que
justement il ya peut-être j'allais dire
une part de gâteau à prendre pour les
autres mouvements politiques qui ne sont
pas qui ne sont pas elles qui ne sont
pas les verts justement quels sont les
partis politiques plus classique mais
est ce que là il ya un effort à faire de
votre côté oui alors l'écologie déjà
elle n'appartient à personne moi je suis
membre du parti de jean-louis borloo de
chantal jouanno qui a été créée partie
de manivelle qui est un parti
profondément écologique sur ces bases
c'est l'engagement que je porte à la
région ile-de-france pour valérie
pécresse l'environnement il n'est pas de
gauche de droite du centre ou d'ailleurs
et ce qui est absolument scandaleux
c'est qu'on a eu depuis des années un
accaparement de la cause
environnementale sur un label dit les
verts anciennement europe ecologie les
verts aujourd'hui il nous en fait c'est
devenu une sorte de pensée unique c'est
devenu une sorte de on vous impose les
tables de la loi parce que si c'est
labellisé versé lot c'est de là que ça
doit venir c'est pas vrai l'écologie
concrète on la forte nous dans les
territoires on la réalise au quotidien
vous avez aujourd'hui herpétologie les
verts c'est la plus grande machine à
green washing qui n'y a jamais eu
on a recyclé toute l'extrême gauche
toute la gauche radicale sous un label
dit environnementale et c'est ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui les gens qui ont
voté de toute bonne foi parce qu'ils
veulent plus dans l'environnement
ils veulent qu'on accompagne une
écologie positive une écologie
soutenable dans leur commune ils ont
voté vert parce qu'ils ont voté pour un
label et ils se sont fait avoir par ce
qu à la place ils ont eu des militants
d'extrême gauche qui se sont repeints en
vert pour profiter d'un vent électoral
je crois qu'il ya un véritable enjeu là
dessus il ya un véritable danger si on
n'explique pas si on ne porte pas ces
sujets là mais de grâce il faut vraiment
arrête de stigmatiser et de caricaturer
les choses et puis vous savez pour finir
je crois qu'on est profondément sur you
un livre avec le peuple contre la
démocratie
moi mon sentiment aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a beaucoup d'élus verts où on a
les zéniths contre le peuple
parce que quand on est contre le tour de
france quand on est contre la patrouille
de france quand on est contre le sapin
de noël qui d'ailleurs peut être planté
si le maire de bordeaux veut pas d'un
arbre mort et bien qu'ils plantent un
sapin en centre ville et il aura pas
besoin de le couper qui s'il est coupé
peut être eu cycle et réutilisées peut
servir pour travailler sur des matériaux
bio sourcés on peut avoir une deuxième
vie derrière on est véritablement sur
des postures qui sont des postures on
vient vendre absolument tout sauf de
l'écologie et je crois qu'on aurait tous
à gagner quel que soit les formations
politiques à s'emparer beaucoup plus
visiblement de ces questions pour pas
laisser à des gens qui aujourd'hui ont
une vision intégriste des choses alors
merci et juste bonjour je m'appelle sur
le tour de france quand même il ya le
maillot jaune mais il ya quand même si
le maillot vert donc il sait aurait pu y
penser
il nous reste à peine moins de huit
minutes alors on va aborder deux sujets
mais je vous demande d aborder
rapidement peut-être quand même un mot
sur les sondages qui montrent une france
très angoissée c'est ce nouveau chapitre
la france envoie c'est alors je vous
demander de réagir assez rapidement
c'est un baromètre ipsos pour le monde
la fondation jean jaurès et l'institut
montaigne 60% de compatriotes pensent
que la modélisation est un danger
on ne parlait tout à l'heure 55 % ils
étaient 46 % l'année dernière déjà enfin
55% sont pour le retour de la peine de
mort
est-ce que très rapidement
stéphane par exemple comprenez ça veut
dire quoi il ya une sorte d'angoissé il
ya et il ya une sorte d'angoissé il ya
une sorte de demande d'un pouvoir fort
et autoritaire est-ce qu'il ne pourrait
crise de l'autorité au fond est ce que
c'est bien des maux de la france
contemporaine
alors dans ce que vous dites ça
s'appelle deux observations de ma part
la première c'est que la france est
angoissé mais je les ai toujours
reconnues en voici un jeu voilà le fond
saveur que méchaal et j'allais faire
cette référence biblique un magistral à
roger gicquel tels que je disais quand
un avion s'écrase
mais il est sûr les choses si maintenant
roger gicquel que les plus jeunes n'ont
pas connu donc pas ce que ça veut dire
être angoissé moi je d'accord vous
pourrez être angoissé par tellement de
choses mais il ya aussi d'aider des
signaux qui peuvent être rassurant et
puis le christ de l'autorité qu'est ce
que vous voulez alors ça irait tellement
mieux si on réinstaurer la peine de mort
on sait parfaitement c'est toujours la
même histoire que patrick henry était à
la soeur sti douala du palais de justice
de trois où on venait de condamner à
mort joe torre buffet choix qu'ils ont
fait dans les buffets bon temps et
buffet et puis le même patrick henry qui
on a retrouvé ensuite 5 yake échappée
qui a échappé à la mort grâce à ça n'est
pas dissuasif c'est pas ça qui va donc
cela la face de la france n'a pas changé
sinon réinstaurer la peine de mort on
sait que ça ne sert à rien de ce point
de vue là la crise d'autorité alors
c'est vrai ça irait tellement mieux si
lg pas le frère de villiers l'homme
général de villiers y est à l'elysée
j'irai le chef nous font un bon chef une
bonne guerre nom de dieu etc
tout fout le camp mais ok chausse ses
skis très paradoxal c'est que à la fois
il ya cette demande donc on voit dans
les sondages et en même temps on voit
des comportements les antilles masque on
voit
les jaunes qui manifestent alors que les
manifestations sont interdites
il ya ces deux courants comme s'il y
avait un peu de france peut-être il y en
a plus de 2 mais ce mec c'est ce que
disait instant tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que maintenant celui qui ne pense
pas comme vous c'est un c'est plus un
adversaire ou quelqu'un avec qui
dialoguer est un ennemi qu'il faut
supprimer donc rééduque on appelait les
choses rééduque on les gens il faut il
faut expliquer que on a le droit de pas
être d'accord et que c'est plutôt bien
qu'on soit pas tous d'accord mais sauf
que à un moment donné il faut tout de
même admettre qu on puisse dû s'avancer
à peu près dans la même direction crise
de l'autorité autorités ça signifie pas
arbitraire et une autorité légitime dès
lors que hal obéit à des canons qui sont
fixées par l'ordre social que non
démocratique républicain le respect des
règles et ces mois l'autorité ne choque
pas si elle est légitime elle me choque
si elle devient arbitre et dans sa
couronne rapidement mais c'est aux
spécialistes du droit européen que je
m'adresse de toute façon le retour de la
peine de mort en france n'est pas
possible tu crois juridiquement non
disons que ça serait possible si on
réviser la constitution et si on sortait
de l'union européenne et qu'on sortait
du contre et de l'europe aussi donc
pourquoi pas à rétablir la peine de mort
on sait que la vie que je faisais mais
je compte y crée c'est assez compliqué
pour en comprendre les conséquences
juste un mot sur la peine de mort dans
un vibrant discours victor hugo contre
la peine de mort disait de deux choses
l'une où l'exemple donné par la peine de
mort et morale où il est immoral si les
morales pourquoi le cas chez vous s'il
est immoral pourquoi le faite vous et
moi la question que je pose de france et
où 55% des français qui sont pour le
rétablissement du permis blanc serait il
prêt à assister à des exécutions au
public comme on pouvait avoir pendant la
guerre en afghanistan
si c'est pas le dire sans hésiter sa
attirer du monde
oui mais si on considère que que
que tu es quelqu'un c'est immoral et
bien dans ces cas là et qu'on doit les
cacher ou non ne règne pas j'imagine que
beaucoup de nos auditeurs ont des
enfants on ne montre pas l'exemple par
une peine immoral tout simplement
hans herren bezina jean charles lajoie
ni et jean philippe dugoin justement
est-ce que ça vous inquiète
au fond ces sondages et qui sont oui
peut-être un peu inquiétant quand même
je suis pas sûr que ce soit les sondages
qui sont inquiétants plutôt que la
perspective qu'on les écoute et qu'on en
fasse demain des décisions tout parce
que c'est vraiment ça m'angoissait ou
parce que si on surjoue sur les passions
des citoyens on va t'aider mais aussi
parce que précisément être c'est aussi
avec choses entre son son seconde
passion et et qui doit être pour
l'avenir du 20h sept ans qu'elle cesse
cette question d'agen on n'a peut-être
pas que vers les monts d'or jean charles
lajoie ni et puis après cristallisée sur
ce problème de peine de mort comme il
très justement vincent et précédemment
sont bons c'est juste ridicule ça avait
valeur d'exemple ça se saurait et puis
on vers les états unis ce n'est pas les
champions du monde les serial killers et
des assassinats absolument horrible
s'est exécuté à tour de bras en chine
aussi donc ça ne sert à rien mais il
faut dépasser cette sorte de de
cristallisation de débile mais c'est
révélateur ce sondage comme de
l'impression qu'on a parce qu'il ya une
injustice l'injustice et le ressenti et
quand on lit les journaux et par exemple
hier après un jugement
ils concernaient des délinquants et des
fins des criminels qui ont commis sujet
des actes assez immonde la fin du papier
précédent parisien dans le figaro
c'était monsieur machin était condamné à
16 mois ferme et laissé en liberté mais
laisse assez juste dramatique dont
l'esprit est dedans c'est à dire
condamnés à 16 mois ferme est ressorti
libre
là le
français qui n'a pas le diplôme
juridique de vin sens des femmes et
internet il ne comprend pas du tout
alors c'est même pas une question de
peine de mort intellectuellement on a du
mal à dire 16 mois ferme et je sens
libre à l'amendé mais qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour aller en prison
mais bien évidemment c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça les prisons sont
pleines et la justice fait bien son
boulot en mai et une communication qui
est curieuse une façon de présenter les
choses et je ne comprends pas comment on
peut être condamné à 16 mois ferme pour
un crime ou un délit extrêmement grave
et que ça n'a l'air de choquer personne
voilà c'est ça me paraît très rapidement
parce qu'il ne reste plus beaucoup plus
de temps
juste pour dire à jean chantepie j'ai
une petite culture aussi les vexer
jusqu'à voilà je serai avec ses 2
jusqu'où on peut aménager des peines en
matière pénale on peut aménager des
peines jusqu'à 24 mois donc il ya un
aménagement de peine il est peut-être
sorti libre mais va y avoir un
aménagement de peine
deuxièmement sur les sondages qu'on a
donnée oui ce que j'aimerais ce qu'on
n'a jamais ce sont les questions qui
sont posées
quelles questions sont posées tout pour
le fc parme
je sais pas qui est l'idée d'aller poser
cette question sera là s'il m'aimait
mais c'est vrai qu'avec elle est signée
mais la recherche d'un pouvoir fort et
le sentiment d'une crise d'autorité jean
philippe dugoin clément votre sentiment
sur cette france comme ça peut-être ce
sentiment d'insécurité peut-être cette
angoisse on est dans un pays qui cherche
qui doutent de lui même qui a plus
confiance en lui même mais c'est par
essence a fait quelques décennies et ça
s'amplifie avec le temps voilà alors sur
la question de la peine de mort on voit
depuis 40 ans tous les sondages de toute
façon quelles que soient les sondages et
les périodes sont toujours favorables à
la peine de mort ça pose une question
tout ça ça pose la question des élus à
être des élus tirent des décideurs pas
être des girouettes qui fonctionne en
fonction des sondages d'opinion en
fonction de l'actualité du 20 heures
mais en fonction de leurs convictions
quand on est élu on n'est pas là pour
répondre à ce sondage
on n'est pas là pour répondre à un
sondage pour ou contre la 5g pour ou
contre la peine de mort pour ou contre
telle ou telle question sociétale
mais pour apporter pour porter ce que
l'on croit profondément bon et essayer
justement de faire que l'opinion
comprenne ce que l'on souhaite porter le
pignon champ
voilà donc moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
si on avait des élus qu'ils soient un
petit peu plus sur ces sujets là
courageux qui soit un petit peu moins un
an dans une logique de chercher à
prendre le sens du vent en fonction
descendeur mais un peu plus dans
l'affirmation de leurs convictions et
dans l'explication du pourquoi de leur
conviction pendant et peut-être aussi
des citoyens un peu moins inquiet et un
peu moins enclins à partir sur toutes
les factures ce qu'on peut vivre
aujourd'hui
et ben puisse les élus vous entende
merci infiniment jean philippe dugoin
clément merci beaucoup
florence muscadet choqué c'était fade
mon son vincent couronne jean charles
lajoie ni et à une certaine bezina
duclair et à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de off
[Musique]